plus que jamais un message que
traditionnellement je porte auprès des
politiques qui consistent à leur dire
attention les lois que vous faites
aujourd'hui où les technologiques vous
mettez en place au sein de la société
pourraient être utilisées à des fins qui
ne sont pas celles que vous avez en tête
le jour où un régime changera là on est
vraiment au coeur du sujet on est à un
an d'un potentiel changement de régime
qui pourrait se saisir une quantité doit
et au final on s'apercevra vite que le
passeport vaccinale et n'est absolument
pas le problème par rapport aux
tombereaux de lois liberticides 1
notamment qui touche à la surveillance
et qui pourraient être instrumentalisés
de façon radicalement différent ce
qu'elles le sont aujourd'hui
là on est vraiment sur la dernière ligne
droite on risque de faire petite erreur
qui se retournera contre nous mais la
réalité c'est que c'est aussi une
occasion de se retourner sur une
quantité de lois liberticides
on a voté ces dix dernières années et de
se dire mon dieu qu'est ce qui va se
passer si vraiment le régime change
c'est c'est aussi une opportunité de
réflexion sur tout ça peut-être soyons
optimistes l'occasion d'en dans le ce
qui nous reste de mode mandat
parlementaire de corriger deux trois
choses de prendre quelques sécurités de
construire quelques garde-fous
mais on est dans une des grandes
problématiques que j'aime a caressé dans
le numérique qui est la responsabilité
des décisions technologique comprend
aujourd'hui dans l'hypothèse d'un
changement radical de régime
ça y est on y est et c'est une
excellente occasion de réfléchir à tout
ça ne donne aucune illusion il y aura un
fichier centralisé de qui est vacciné et
c'est pas vraiment là que se situe le
plus grand danger
[Musique]